[Music]
this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your host and your personal
astrophysicist
and i got with me today my co-host chuck
knight jack
hey neil how are you always good to have
you chuck and you're always cheerful and
and got a nice smile it's all a lie neil
it's just a facade i'm i'm very well
media trained
so today we've got really a hot topic
oh my gosh we're going to talk about
crispr that gene
editing tool we're going to talk about
the origin of life
and what role rna did or did not play
in that and i have no expertise in this
at all
so uh we we're gonna feature an
interview
with jennifer doudna who is an
expert in this in fact she's a
co-invented crisper
and in fact was recognized by the 2020
nobel prize yeah the nobel prize for
that
and not only that i'm bringing in
somebody he's actually an old friend
not old old friend but a recent
acquaintance
uh walter isaacson uh walter welcome to
star talk
hey it's great to be with you neil yeah
walter i mean your
your bio if i went through your bio we
have no room for the show
so let me let me cherry cherry-pick it
if i may author
journalist professor of history at
tulane university
uh and you co-host uh amanpour and
company
with christian amanpour and formerly the
ceo of the aspen institute in colorado
that's a
place where very deep thinking people go
to have deep thoughts
and one-time editor of time magazine
chair of cnn so
you've got the pedigree but more
important for this program
you you're a biographer of really
important
thinkers who have shaped our
understanding of this world and
civilization
you've got the best-selling biographies
of leonardo da vinci
einstein steve jobs
benjamin franklin and benjamin frank i
think of him as a scientist
even though many think of him as a
founding father and surely you got all
up in that story
but you've also become the biographer of
jennifer doudna
oh my gosh in a new book called the code
breakers
and i thought i'd get to you before this
book sailed away it's i
hit number one on the times bestseller
so you don't even need this pr
so i'm just saying you know doing it for
the greatness and fun of being with you
yeah okay that that's great so let me
ask you did you
start this sort of uh work as a
biographer
of jennifer downer i had to well before
the nobel prize was announced so what
what was the trigger here that got you
into it because i think she's the only
one of your
people you have biographied that
was alive at the time the book came out
well yes uh about recent biographies
that's true
and i wanted to be able to take on the
life sciences revolution
you know through einstein was able to do
the physics revolution of the first half
of the 20th century
and then through steve jobs do the
digital revolution
but i think even more consequential will
be this revolution where molecules
from the new microchips we can reprogram
them to do our bidding
to make the proteins we want if we need
a vaccine against covet
to be the guide that will help us
chop up our dna and maybe edit it and
add things to our
genome so to me that's like the most
consequential revolution
of our time and uh jennifer doudna was a
perfect central character she's somebody
who
starts off by marveling on dna but then
she does the structure of rna
she co-discovers the crispr technology
the gene editing technology
you talked about she's been involved
with the covid
uh fight against covet she wins the
nobel prize
and uh she even more importantly in some
ways now
is gathering the scientists the
politicians the ethicists
to say when should we be using these
gene editing tools so what a wonderful
central character she is
and and she shared the nobel prize uh my
notes show here
uh emmanuel chappentier a french
biochemist
is that right absolutely they met in
puerto rico at a conference and
bonded together like two chemical
compounds
i flew on over to berlin uh
which is where emmanuel sharpened jay's
lab is
and spent a lot of time with her it was
a wonderful collaboration the two of
them had
and jennifer's had other collaborations
along the way
but it's the first time two women
scientists alone
have won a nobel prize like that so it
was
pretty fortuitous both for the book but
i think for the time we're in
uh to have jennifer dowden and emmanuel
charpentier suddenly become world heroes
now nobel's rules are that you can award
up to
three people in one category in any
given year
in that year it only went to those two
right
they didn't even bring anybody else into
that list a little surprising a little
surprising to me i
set my alarm for 4 am so i could watch
the live stream
thinking it was a bit too early for the
crisper technology to win a nobel
but i let out a shout when they said
these scissors
will rewrite the code of life and change
science into a new apoc
and uh then i waited for the names and
it was emmanuel and then jennifer
i thought it was going to be fong zhang
as well the
competitor they have at the broad
institute of mit and harvard
but in some ways what he did was show
how it can work in human selves
and i'm hoping maybe someday he and
george church
uh win the nobel prize for medicine uh
you're telling me you woke up at four in
the morning to listen to
um well who does that why except for
you yeah well i mean i was writing a
book about jennifer doudna and emmanuel
sharpente and
all the other players oh i get it so you
let out a shout out
you know you know who let out a bigger
shout you're a publisher
no who did not let out a shout who's
that
jennifer doudna she slept through it she
did not
uh wake up and when she wakes up finally
there's all these missed phone calls
from stockholm
now i've never had that experience of
seeing missed phone call from stockholm
on my cell phone that was pretty amazing
yeah that's uh that's what we call a
baller move oh yeah yeah
where where you're so confident you're
like yeah i'm a i'm going to go to sleep
and i'm badass and they can wait you
know stockholm can wait
stockholm can wait yes well her career
began
studying rna and and our
origin of life we think possibly began
with rna
so i chatted with her about her origins
let's check it out
well this takes me back to when i was uh
first starting my
my graduate work and my advisor jack
shostak was fascinated by the question
of the origin of life and
he and a few other people at the time
wondered whether
rna molecules might in many ways hold
the clues
to life's uh you know to life's origins
on earth by
providing the the link between dna which
is now the material the genetic material
that is used in
all cells as far as we know there are
viruses that use
rna in some cases as its genetic
material for example the
coronavirus the virus that causes
covid19 is an rna
virus and and the fascinating thing
about rna
and the reason why i got interested in
it is because
it's a molecule that has fundamentally
the ability to not only encode
genetic information but also to do
chemistry
so that means that rna molecules have
the ability to form
three-dimensional shapes that allow them
to do things like
cut and paste other molecules of rna and
some people think that
that might have even allowed very
primitive forms of
rna to make copies of themselves and
that would potentially have formed the
basis for a self-replicating
rna-based system or world early on
in the origin of life so that was how i
originally got interested in it
and what's happened over the last few
decades really since i
did my graduate work in the 80s over the
last few decades scientists studying
rna have come to realize that rna is
doing all sorts of really interesting
things in cells that we didn't know
about at the time so
we know now that rna molecules are
helping cells decide
when and where to make proteins they're
helping
cells decide uh how to how to regulate
different parts of the chromosome and
they're also involved
in things like crispr that help cells
protect themselves from
viruses and i'm sure there's a lot of
other things that haven't yet been
discovered about rna
okay so then all right so if rna is the
is the contractor the construction
contractor
oh we need some of these aren't fold
this way or you need some of that do
this chemistry
um is there any insight into how you get
the rna
itself how you go from organic molecules
to rna
is there where are we on that frontier
well we certainly know how rna is made
in modern cells
we don't really know where it originated
from if we're going to rewind the clock
if we had a time machine we could go
back and see
what was going on and i'm working on
that time machine
okay i want a ticket
but yeah you know i think i think
understanding how
rna came into existence in the early
uh you know early years of the earth is
is very much a mystery it's not known
some people think so francis crick who
is one of the
co-discoverers of the structure of dna
came to feel that life might have been
seeded from
outside of our uh our earth you know and
and that maybe
rna came in from somewhere else so some
people think that might be the case so
the answer is that we don't know it's a
mystery right now
yeah so if if it came if we came from
mars
that would mean we're all descendants of
martians that would be kind of fun
or perhaps perhaps some people are more
descendant than others of martians
yeah so she was talking about that's
basically we say in astrobiology
the panspermia hypothesis but if if
life on earth came from mars then you
still have the question of how life on
mars began so so walter here she is
getting all
into rna but but recent memory tells me
that
her whole world her her
scientific community was all about dna
and the human genome project and
recombinant dna and gene therapy
so how does she end up swimming upstream
against all of that to end up
focusing on rna when i wrote about her
childhood she said
she loved playing soccer but unlike the
boys she wasn't always running to the
ball she liked playing positions where
others weren't playing
and getting a sense of the whole field
so in the 1990s when a lot of the alpha
males that you know so well neil
were in part of the human genome project
sequencing dna
she was there as she said with jack just
stack studying
rna and it turns out that rna is a far
more interesting molecule and when you
ask about where did the rna come from
how did life begin
just as the the primordial soup of
chemicals
four billion years ago rna is pretty
simple and if it jostles together
and those four letters of rna it can
replicate itself as jennifer showed
and maybe that it just started
replicating itself
so those those four letters you're
referring to the amino acid letters
the letters which are similar to the dna
four letters but there's a one letter
difference just to
make sure that biology students are
staying awake for that lesson okay good
and gene editing as an activity has very
high precision
with crispr i can imagine without that
level of precision
it's kind of like a crapshoot or may if
it's not a crap shoot it's
there's risks involved that are
minimized with crispr is that right
yeah and you can still have off target
edits but the great thing about crispr
technology is it's advancing in leaps
and bounds
and so when we talk about a nobel prize
i think david lew
at harvard might also win one from
madison because he's created things like
base editing and prime editing
where if uh crispr is like a scissors
that can cut dna
these are fine pencil points that can do
it exactly right and then even
edit in a sequence and even do multiple
genes
so really in the 10 years since jennifer
doudna and emmanuel sharpen jay made
their discovery
we keep advancing on that genetic
editing front
so to make sure we're all on the same
page and all of our listeners i actually
got jennifer to describe
precisely how crispr works so let's
check it out it's quite amazing
it's a system that evolved originally in
bacteria as a way that bacteria fight
viral infection so in the natural world
there's a lot of
viral infection going on all the time in
bacteria so there's
a lot of evolutionary pressure to
develop ways to
fend off these viruses and one of those
pathways
is called crispr and what it does
is provide cells a way to
steal snippets of virus dna
and store them as a record of that virus
and that and then use that molecular
information to fight the viral
virus if it shows up in the cell and so
by studying how it works
and in particular a protein that's
called
cas9 that allows bacteria to
program cas9 with these little snippets
of information
that help these proteins find viruses
and if they find them
what cas9 does is to cut and its job is
to cut
dna that in a way that in bacteria leads
to destruction of the viral dna
but in our cells or plant or animal
cells
it can be used to make cuts that will
trigger cells to
change the dna sequence during the
process of dna repair and that's
fundamentally how gene editing works
with crispr
wow wait wait so what you're saying is
um we're finally as smart as bacteria
because they've been doing this for a
billion years i wouldn't go that far
neil
so so walter i'm told that you
they allowed you to edit a gene yourself
did they really let a journalist into a
lab to do this oh man it was so exciting
to be in
the lab with jennifer and a couple of
her graduate students
and you know i like to learn to do by
doing
and the way we did it was we first
edited
a bacteria cell which is sort of what
happened in the 2012 paper
that jennifer and emanuel did that won
the nobel prize
and then the next day we took the step
that fong jiang
jennifer doudna george church do and see
if he could do it in a human cell so i
did it
in a human kidney cell and it was pretty
easy in the lab which was probably the
most frightening thing about it
but i don't want you to worry neil we
took it afterwards and
mixed it with chlorine and poured it
down the drain and flushed it
so my edited cells are not part of the
planet earth there's not some new
creature crawling out from under the
rock
i was going to say somewhere in the
sewer right now there's a chlorine
monster
chlorine there's a chlorine monster
somewhere in the sewer that is just now
getting its legs
so i checked with jennifer to see how
far away we are from this process
possibly editing more complex human
traits
than what might simply be encoded in a
single gene so let's check it out
this probably won't come as a surprise
to many people that
um in fact there isn't a single gene for
musical ability or
or you know astrophysical inclinations
or
you know things like that that we can
put our finger on and in fact
it's you know by far typically the case
that for human traits there are
probably dozens if not hundreds or even
more
genes that are involved and so the
reality of you know genome editing
to create uh people that have you know
particular
intellectual capabilities for example is
i think you know a distant uh
possibility
however again you know just circling
back to what is possible
i think you know already on the horizon
we have the potential to manipulate
individual genes that are known to
either
directly cause disease or you know give
people a sort of a
propensity to develop disease and i'll
give you a couple of examples so
you know i think many folks are familiar
with a disease called sickle cell
disease or sickle cell anemia so that
that is a very well characterized
genetic disease that results from a
single mutation in a single gene
in in the human genome and crispr is
capable of correcting it or making a
an ameliorating change elsewhere in the
genome and that's actually already being
done in patients and it's already been
shown to be effective
so you know it's extraordinary and it's
kind of already giving
everybody in the field uh the the sense
that you know we're on the verge of
being able to
provide potentially a cure for that type
of genetic disease where there's a
single gene that
causes a uh disorder and you know
another example
is muscular dystrophy uh cystic fibrosis
is in this category and and there are
there are
quite a few others so i think you know
that's where crispr is gonna have a real
impact
walter i it's not surprising i guess
that
darpa took interest in this technology
the defense
advanced research projects
what does the a stand for in that agency
agency so what is it that they what
what are they going to do with it you
know first of all a
malevolent actor or enemy power could
decide to use crispr to do anything from
creating gene drives that will change
mosquitoes so that they can
carry deadly pathogens or as vladimir
putin said to a youth conference in
moscow maybe we'll use crispr to create
soldiers that don't feel pain or don't
feel fear
oh that's vlady he's such a romantic
and uh so you can imagine the defense
department is one of the biggest
spenders in this area
they've come up with and a person who's
been working with jennifer was part of
it
something called anti-crispr which is
pretty much
uh what it sounds like and just like we
may have ballistic missile systems and
russia may have them
we develop anti-ballistic missile
systems so
i think we have to guard against you
know bad
actors using this technology so science
fiction becoming
science it's that it always happens
doesn't it neil man yeah that's that's
the thing about really great science
fiction is that half of it's already
happened
we're going to take a quick break but
when we return we're going to address
the
philosophical and ethical implications
of crispr when star talk returns
we're back star talk chuck nice co-host
jack
hey neil you're tweeting at chuck nice
comic thank you sir okay i like i like
your
your occasional posts there they make me
smile
but sometimes they're like making fun of
other people and i guess that's still
okay sometimes
i i am a comedian and so that's how that
works
[Laughter]
so we're talking about gene editing oh
my gosh and we're featuring my interview
with biochemist jennifer doudna and
recently winning
sharing the nobel prize in this very
subject and walter
isaacson the one and only biographer of
genius out there
as well as other things he's done in his
career of course and i want to
talk about the ethical challenges that
this
technology brings and
uh let me actually begin with a clip of
jennifer doudna addressing the
difference
between somatic editing and
germline editing in the crispr
technology so let's check it out
germline means changing dna in embryos
or other kinds of germ cells like
eggs or sperm basically cells that can
produce an entire
organism and if dna is altered in those
cells
then the those changes become part of
the entire organism
and furthermore they can be inherited by
future generations so it's a heritable
change to the dna
which is very different in my mind from
somatic cell editing which means editing
cells that are already
fully developed so they're not going to
be able to
produce a new organism or pass their
changes on to future generations they
might they might make
they might make new cells that have
those changes in an individual
but they won't be inherited by future
individuals and that's
fundamentally different than germline
editing to me
because it remains localized in one
individual rather than being passed on
to future generations
okay so that's good or bad for example
if i have
sickle cell or tay sachs less likely tay
sachs
but if i have one of these that you have
identified the gene and and
i'm a a full human being
you can remove those those disease
symptoms from me
and the disease entirely but i still
carry that into my offspring
correct so so why wouldn't you want
germline editing well you might want to
right i mean i think there may come a
time when we decide that it would be
unethical not to do that
in the germline for certain certain
types of disease
i don't think that time is now i don't
think the technology is where it needs
to be for one thing
and also i don't think that uh you know
society is ready for this like how do we
ensure
equitable use affordable access all of
those sorts of things
but you know if we set all that aside
for the moment i think what you just
said is a is
a very real possibility that in the
future the technology is robust and we
decide that
uh we meaning you know i don't know who
he is really here but you know maybe a
parent
would decide that you know i would
really like to not
pass this trait on to um my children and
furthermore i don't want my children to
have to deal with it when they come
around time for them to have kids and so
i'm just going to get rid of it
once and for all by editing the germline
that that
that could happen in the future walter
most conversations about crispr
are not so much about the innovative
science
of it but about the ethical and moral
implications
and you devote justifiably a significant
real estate in your book addressing
these issues can you can you help
help us through how bad it could get
relative to how good it could get well i
think most of what will happen will be
really good because every creature large
and small on this planet uses every
trick in its playbook
to say okay how can i thrive how can i
survive and i think humans can and will
and should do that
the question is when you start doing
things that could be
problematic one thing that would be
problematic is if we just let this be a
free market thing
where rich people can buy better genes
for their children
and make them taller or make them you
know boost uh
whatever their muscle mass whatever they
want to do
and not only will that uh uh increase
the inequality in our society
it will encode it permanently in our
species which would just be
a eugenic horror show uh you know like
brave new world of the movie gattaca we
don't want that to happen
the other thing is that one of the
really important things about
the species that makes it creative but
also makes it uh
you know resilient helps it survive is
that we have a lot of diversity in this
species people
tall and short and fat and skinny and
gay and straight and trans and you know
different hues and different backgrounds
and
different personalities and if all of a
sudden
parents are saying here's the model
child we want we won't
we won't have a great diversity in our
species i think those are science
fictiony in the moment meaning
we're talking 20 30 40 years away but
when jennifer says
we should decide this but then says who
is we i'll answer that question
we as me and you and everybody listening
to this podcast
we ought to be somewhat familiar with
these problems that are going to happen
we're all screwed walter just showed us
him if it's up to us as a society we're
oh well wait wait walter it is
it is inevitable that if we can
remove bad traits that we can add good
traits so
you'll say that's not good but what's
gonna stop it
who's how's that gonna do is is there
are you imagining a realistic future
here rather than a utopian future
oh yeah i mean i think there are all
sorts of medical procedures that either
get approved or don't get approved oh
okay uh whether they're drugs or
approvals
and yeah and i think we have
international conferences i've jennifer
doudna
in my book we you know i travel with her
and
she gathers people from around the world
and so the chinese academy one of the
characters in my book is
drong ching pay who is one of the people
at the chinese academy
uh robin level badge at the royal
academy in england
all these people trying to figure it out
and once you have an international
consensus and things get regulated
sure some people will be using off
target you know
pharmaceuticals some people be
trafficking in elephant
tusks but we can try to minimize those
things by saying they're not legal
so i'm gonna say but doesn't it i mean
if once you
once you do have a road map as to what
is indeed
ethical inevitably what you will have
created is a black market
for those who want to circumvent those
those ethical guidelines and create
whatever the hell they want to create
that's what he just said about the tusks
so that's what i'm saying yeah so
no so uh but it's easy my point
that's my question it's easy to find the
person
who is trafficking in tusk how do you
find the person
who made my kid lebron james when
both my parents are white but yes
somehow
here i am lebron james the greatest
basketball player ever
like we don't have any idea how that
happened like how do you how would you
even
police you can't do that on a street
corner right
well you know a lot of things are kind
of hard to police
but you know we can't stop it all i
think we're going to be able to save our
species if we make sure that
maybe one percent of the cases sneak
through
because people engage in medical tourism
or they find
some back channel way to have gene
editing in the
next 30 40 50 years but i think we as a
society
are pretty good at saying these are the
things we aren't going to do whether it
be through regulation or just social
shaming
well check chuck we have a sort of
example of that because back in 2018 uh
there was scientists in china that used
crispr to
actually edit the embryos
of unborn human embryos
to make them hiv resistant and so i just
had to ask jennifer
about that and get her reaction to
what it means in the present and in the
future check it out
yeah so this this story was um
you know probably the most shocking uh
so far with crispr honestly
because in this situation a scientist
had actually used crispr in human
embryos not just for
research which has been done in other
labs but
for the purpose of implanting those
embryos
to create a pregnancy and in fact that
did occur
and uh those those children were were
born
and as you mentioned neil the the stated
purpose of that
uh that work was to protect those kids
from
future infection by hiv using a crispr
based approach where their cells were
were you know edited so they couldn't
express a protein that's necessary for
hiv infection
so while that might sound like a good
idea
at a high level it turns out that there
are already
very well known um you know other ways
of treating or
preventing hiv infection for kids that
are
born to parents that might have a
pre-existing hiv infection
and also i think in this in this
instance it was
absolutely irresponsible and frankly
just flatly unethical
to use it in uh in this way because uh
for many reasons but one of them is that
you know the parents i don't think could
really understand
uh the technology or just how how
experimental
it was and how untested it was i mean to
do this on your children is you know
kind of the most extreme
um use of something like this and also
just that
you know i think even the the the data
that were published for that particular
uh application showed that the
technology itself is just not not ready
for that kind of use we don't have
enough control over it yet in embryos to
use it safely
right but so so how do you regulate it
then do you just make it so
socially and ethically objectionable
that there's
cultural pressure against it or or do
you need actual laws
governmental laws and international
treaties or regulations surrounding it
what's that going to take
well i certainly think the former is is
probably the most
um you know the most realistic strategy
right now and that means
basically creating a you know a culture
around
the technology that supports what i
would call responsible use
and and and really really um
uh makes a very strong statement against
unethical or just you know uninformed
frankly uh uses of the technology
and that's what had what happened after
that announcement in 2018 i think there
was a
really interesting kind of international
rejection
of that work um it was uh not
published in uh you know i think in the
end i don't really think that that
uh that a manuscript reporting that
study was
was published anywhere you know in any
kind of a peer reviewed
journal even though it had been
submitted to those journals uh but you
know
those journals said you know we're not
we're not going to to support this we're
not going to publish it it was not done
in an ethical fashion and this is just
some simply not work that we're going to
publicize and uh so that would be
scientists
policing ourselves in that sense and
that has tremendous value
right so i think it's very important i
think it's you know the the reality
is that it's and you you you have seen
this in in other fields you know that
it's very difficult for governments to
um to first of all even to draft you
know
legislation that would be suitable uh
for controlling technologies and look at
look at the challenges with things like
social media right very difficult to
police it how do we
how do we do that appropriately it's not
they don't even know what questions to
ask
right right very difficult right it's
very hard
and then even if you could draft
legislation how would you ever enforce
it and how would you enforce it globally
i think it's unrealistic
so to me the better approach or just the
more realistic approach is frankly just
to
really engage the the the you know the
scientists and the technologists
in this and create a culture around the
the technology
that uh very strongly supports
uh the the you know the i would call it
the appropriate and ethical use of the
technology
walter just a moment ago you were
referring to you me
chuck and others common folk to
to have a say in the ethical use of this
technology
but uh it wasn't that long ago really
when eugenics was sort of sweeping sort
of the western world
as a way of improving the human species
breeding out the bad traits breeding in
the good traits
and there were panels and committees and
surely at that time they considered
homosexuality something you're going to
have to breed that out because that's
deviant
so what kind of thinking have you done
about what might be the evolution of a
morality
from one time to another yes it's a
great
question and in the book i talk about
the fact that
yes we had state-sponsored eugenics
whether it was in the united states in
the
early 1900s and of course in nazi
germany
but i think we also have to get our
minds around what could be happening if
you had a
free market and maybe a free market
eugenics
you talk about homosexuality i think
nowadays people would be appalled at the
notion that we would try to edit
our you know sexual orientation of our
child
or change it in some way but if you left
it to every parent and to the free
market
who knows what choices a individual
families may make
and yet in our system in the united
states in particular
we tend to leave reproductive choices
to the individual or to the family and
so
this is where we're going to get into
some conflict in figuring this out
because i think sometimes it changes if
you're in a fertility clinic and
it's confidential and nobody knows what
you can pick you might pick the gender
you might pick the
gender orientation you might pick
anything
uh as your designer baby closed
behind closed doors and so i think
that's why our whole morality has to
change
we have to say what are true
disabilities
such as having tay sachs or sickle cell
and what are things that we may
that society may uh cause to be
disabilities
but shouldn't be and i think we have to
make sure
that we don't label things as bad just
because
society has prejudices because as you
said
there were prejudices 20 30 40 years ago
we would find abhorrent
but here's my prediction 20 30 40 years
from now
people will look back at us and find our
prejudices
well two things one hopefully the first
thing that they're able to
edit out completely is asininism
okay so you know if we if we can get rid
of
them a lot of that stuff will take care
of itself
so that's a gene for that they just
found it
that guy's an egg hole we found the gene
we found the gene to get rid of
the second thing the second thing though
that that i will say
is somewhat frightening is
that even now very recently
there is a world power government
that was very much involved
in the fertility decisions of
its citizens so you know
what happens when governments say you
know what
for these reasons we need to do thus and
so
so perhaps there needs to be treaties
immediately worked upon
to make sure that with this technology
governments themselves
don't take actions to uh interfere
with people's decisions in these areas
absolutely and i think that
one way to help push back in that in the
long run
is for individuals for real people to
understand this technology
figure out what they're comfortable with
and even in authoritarian regimes
if the people truly have a sense of
morality about something
the leaders will eventually have to
follow them and so i had to ask jennifer
about sort of the fear factor involved
in designer babies let's check out her
reply is the fear factor
um justified
yes and no i think it's important to be
you know realistic about what the
technology can
and cannot do right now or even in the
future
is it going to allow us to create super
soldiers for example
uh no i don't think that's happening
anytime soon
but you know does it have the potential
to allow
parents who are using in vitro
fertilization to
make tweaks to their their children's
dna yes it does and so that does bring
along
i think very important questions uh
ethical and otherwise that have to be
addressed
um and and so that's where i sort of
feel that you know having that
conversation now
even while the technology is still
developing is very important
that's really good so that it doesn't
bite us in the ass when it's too late
yeah i i hope that's the case for sure
we got to take another break but when we
return
walter i want to get into what role
crispr may have played
in the race to find a vaccine for
this virus this pandemic that we're in
when star talk returns
we're back star talk we're talking about
gene editing we're talking about crispr
and in this segment we're bringing covid
into the mix
and we're featuring my interview with
jennifer doudna biochemist
who invented crispr somebody had to do
it there she was with
some close colleagues of hers and we've
got the person who
has served as her biographer in this
modern time walter isaacson
walter it's always good to see you and
always good to hear what you have to say
and of course uh chuck nice um that
means to sound like
it sounds like oh and chuck knight of
course because that's exactly what it
was
no i mean here i am let's be honest i'm
sitting here with the world's
most renowned science educator and the
world's
most renowned biographer of course it's
going to be
oh yeah and chuck knight
we love you chuck uh jennifer
if you only just joined us jennifer
actually won the nobel prize in 2020.
walter she won it in biochemistry why
didn't she win it in
human physiology because that's a whole
other category and it seems like that
would be appropriate
are they saving that category for more
uh
more rewards for this discovery it was a
basic discovery in science it's how the
chemistry
of this tool works and it was done
in labs and done in test tubes and so i
think it was appropriate that it was the
chemistry prize
i do think people are now applying it to
humans
and using it as a medical tool and i
hope eventually
that some of the people doing that
including george church and fong jiang
who first
showed how it could be used in human
cells and david liu
who's creating new ways to use crispr
technology
for editing in humans that someday they
may win the prize in medicine
okay so that's so this is this is the
right way this would happen
because the there's a their conduits
that connect branches of science that
are in nature that does it all the time
and it's kind of artificial that we even
do it at all
so the fact that you have a basic
chemistry discovery that gets exploited
in the service of the human condition
that that makes perfect sense walter
just just the way you describe that let
me ask you tell me about competition
in science and what you've discovered in
your
as a biographer of her work jennifer's
work
you know competition is a good thing in
my opinion and she's a competitive
person and some people say
that i think meaning it to be slightly
insulting and i say yeah she's very
competitive
isn't that great and when she heard
footsteps in 2012
when she and emmanuel charpentier were
doing this discovery
about crispr but there were lithuanian
scientists working on it there are
people in different labs
she pushed hard to get it done fast in
competition as you know
that's what causes us to work weekends
that was what caused jennifer doudna
in california and emmanuel sharpened j
in europe
to work around the clock by handing
things off to each other when sunset
happened
in one place or the other so i think
that competition was good but
at the end when kovitz struck they
decided
the labs around the world to put aside
some of the competition
and to make discoveries out in the open
sharing the information
and not asserting patent rights well
okay so this is that this is an uh
this is duty rises above the
what was otherwise the competitive
spirit personal glory
it's a back seat it's good to know that
that still exists and you make an
excellent point walter about competition
in science where
initially you might think of it as some
kind of a dig on someone but
almost everything else we do in this
world thrives on competition you go to
sporting events
you go to a track meet you want to see
who wins and the runners
want to win right so and you celebrate
that and the struggle that gets you
there so
there's no reason why science shouldn't
be any different especially if the end
if in the end the results are valuable
discoveries
so what precisely did they do to help
covet
well you know when covid struck about a
year ago
in march of last year jennifer dowden
had dropped her 17 year old son
off at a robot building camp
and she woke her husband up at two in
the morning said we got to go back to
fresno
and pick up andy because i don't want
him there in this convention center
now that i hear about this pandemic and
andy's an only child he's rolling his
eyes but as they leave the parking lot
they get a text message saying robot
competition
canceled and that's when jennifer
decided to gather
people throughout the bay area the
scientists and
focus their attention on turning their
tools to fighting coronavirus
likewise fong zhang and the people the
broad institute in cambridge mass
did the same and what they do are
multiple things one
is you can easily use crispr as we've
talked about
as a detection technology to detect the
genetic material of coronavirus
and testing was a real cock-up
during this pandemic now we're going to
be able to have at-home testing kits
that work
instantly secondly we can fight
coronavirus the next time around
the way bacteria do which is not by
stimulating our immune system which is
kind of a messy process
but just by detecting the virus in our
system and cutting it
up and killing it and thirdly
that whole notion of using rna as
something you can
code which goes back to jennifer
doudna's graduate work
that's what we're doing with the pfizer
and modern vaccines which is
we're coding rna to be a messenger
to tell our own cells what little
proteins to produce
that will create immunity to the virus
so this so which is it fair to say that
without the crispr technology we might
still be
reaching for for vaccines at this point
well no i think the vaccines come out of
the earlier work we've done on
rna which is that you can code it to be
a guide which is what crispr is
or you can encode it to be a messenger
telling ourselves to build proteins and
it was the latter
that's involved in these pfizer and
modern vaccines
but if it's going to be the treatments
or the treatments that don't even
involve vaccines that'll even be
better that's going to be crisper
directly chopping up the virus
oh so so it formed an important
motivating force
to further expand the power of
crispr over our destiny is that a fair
characteristic
and it also showed as we said at the
beginning of the show
that rna is the miracle molecule it's
the star of my book along with jennifer
doudna
and it's like having a microchip
if you can code rna to do your bidding
you can make vaccines and you can make
gene editing tools
and how long did you take you to write
this book the code breakers you know for
seven or eight years i've been gathering
string on it because i've been wanting
to
write about the health sciences i was
finishing up leonardo but i kept meeting
jennifer doudna
and i also met george church who you
know and i've met
fong jiang and eric lander and many
other people in the book
and i was trying to figure it out right
we can't just go by his name that
quickly eric lander
is now the very first uh
the very first cabinet science post
ever in the history of the country eric
lander a really good choice by uh joe
biden
yes secretary of science for the first
time yeah exactly
and it's a great choice because what
eric lander has shown is his
magnetic ability to bring together
talent and he built the broad institute
into the best place on the planet
for translating genetics into medicine
and uh he's you know people talk about
competitive
he's as competitive as they come he
competed against jennifer doudna
with his team but they all know that
they were part of a
more noble mission in a higher calling
can i ask a question that is unrelated
but i'm just gotta know okay
okay and we can always cut this i think
out of the video
okay we can always cut it okay but it's
killing me i gotta know this from work
i'm preparing to dock i'm preparing the
dock without intro like that
okay so check it out so all these
brilliant people that you have
chronicled
their lives and their accomplishments
who do you like best
okay well you know as a person there's
nobody more
likeable than jennifer doudna and i tell
you i've written about some people
and i knew steve jobs pretty well i was
spending a lot of time with him when i
was doing that book
steve jobs was brilliant he drove people
crazy he drove him to distraction he
also drove him
to do things that they never dreamed
they would be able to do
but nobody said he was the coziest
warmest fuzziest person they had ever
met
jennifer is cozy and gentle and loves to
mentor people
and so i would put her and benjamin
franklin
as the two people who seem uh
just the person you want to have dinner
with or a beer with
and and by the way i share those same
sentiments when i when we laid down the
tracks
of the interviews work we've just cut in
uh i said
i just want to stay on for like three
hours of course she she's busy
she's got other other things but it was
it was just it was
a delight to just be educated by her and
just to have her have her do all the
talking
that that was great so i i had to ask
jennifer
what did she see what might be in the
future
of crispr because will that pave the way
for
curing cancer and other diseases that
have been a blight on our civilization
will in a hundred years we look back
in the primitive 2020s and say oh look
at all the diseases that they
the our species once had so let's see
what she has to say about this
so jennifer what's the future of the
science of crispr will it just get
cheaper and faster and now you can do it
in your kitchen
or and what else are you working on i
don't know about doing it in your
kitchen but it's certainly going to get
cheaper and faster and better over time
it already is
and yeah i think i think we're going to
see you know increasing
uses in in clinical medicine i think
we're going to see we didn't talk about
this today
neil but a big big area of impact for
crispr is and agriculture
we have a big effort right now at the
innovative genomics institute that i
founded a few years ago to use crispr
to address climate change and i think
that's going to be
you know a very interesting kind of area
of development of this technology and
and for myself
yeah i mean we're we're continuing to do
fundamental research in my academic lab
on crispr uh molecules understanding how
they work and also
really digging into the ways that that
this technology will become affordable
and widely available in the future for
um you know
for for solving real world problems you
know
walter you said earlier that you were
worried about the
inequality gap growing if only the rich
people can afford
crispr and touch up their offspring and
the poor people can't but if it becomes
very affordable like for example let's
just look at
self you know smartphones even poor
people have smartphones
so the technology though it's still
costly
it wasn't out of reach of people who
were not otherwise rich
so is there a future where it is
accessible to everyone and therefore you
can't invoke
the inequality argument you can't play
that card anymore
that's what we should be aiming for and
it's a great question neil and it's a
great comparison
to digital technology which had the
ability to create
a digital divide and probably did during
this pandemic
you know when people were having the
students were having to study from home
there was somewhat of a digital divide
but as you said we've been able to
try to make digital technology
widespread
and the cost keeps going down because
the cost of microchips keeps going down
now when it comes to crispr that should
be our goal
i was in jennifer dowd in his lab with a
guy named fyodor
yurnov about one of the most colorful
characters in the book
and his job there is bring the cost down
because when victoria gray got cured
last year of sickle cell
that was about a million dollars that
treatment but if you could do it
in the body rather than extract the stem
cells and have to reinsert them
you can bring the cost down dramatically
and so that should be our goal for the
next phase of crispr
is say let's make this health
part of this technology the one that
cures bad disabilities
let's make it as available as possible
so is it possible that we'll get to a
place where instead
of in in the truest sense of
manipulation we're just trying to make
things better in other words this is
what you
we already see you do well we've
identified that like
you do this well you do that well what
we're going to do is augment that to the
best
of your ability i mean
how do you how do you feel i'm asking
you too neil how do you guys feel about
that
ethically as a means of manipulating
gene expression
i think one thing about that chuck that
would be good is that it preserves the
diversity and respects the individuality
of people
and it says well you know you joked i
think you were making me into lebron
james or somebody
well you know that ain't going to be me
but i think every person can
first of all have the disabilities
things that are true disabilities
you know muscular dystrophy that's a
disability or even
problematic you know genetic
conditions you have let's remove those
so that every person can flourish
to the extent their abilities and their
desires
uh lead them to it seems to me there
would always be this sort of fuzzy
boundary between what anyone is
declaring
should be fixed and what shouldn't be
absolutely the boundary is fuzzy and in
my book
i try to make us open our minds a bit to
say what are true disabilities
and what are things that are
disabilities only because society
doesn't accommodate them well and those
of us in the hearing enabled community
we may say
we want to make sure our kids don't have
congenital deafness
but if you're in the deaf community you
might say we're adding a lot to our
society
i don't think there's easy answers to
things like that even david sanchez as i
mentioned in my book says well those of
us who have sickle cell
you know sickle cell drove miles davis
to drink it drove him to drugs it
probably drove him to death
but it also drove miles davis to do
bitch's brew
or kind of blue some of the greatest uh
and so we have to march down this path
by understanding yes you know
franklin roosevelt was forged by polio
but that doesn't mean
we're going to quit using the polio
vaccine uh
sickle cell may have forged miles davis
but what does that mean should we be
editing out sickle cell should we be
editing out
deafness shortness these are not easy
answers but in my book
i walk through talking to people in all
the communities including what we
sometimes call
the disabled community and say hey let's
open our minds a bit
because this is an interesting ethical
journey we're about to go on
the differently abled community that
that is so walter i think i have the
solution
you do edit out the sickle cell gene but
you edit back in the gene for jazz
and that way you still get the winner
everybody's a winner all around yeah
you're talking to somebody
in new orleans in new orleans you're
homebound anthony overlooks royal street
and at the moment doreen ketchins is
playing her clarinet
and i want to edit that gene in because
i've learned i would
love to play clarinet i used to play it
pretty well
and i want that gene so i can play it
again well i'm glad you didn't play so
that you can write these books
walter it's great to have you on the on
the landscape
among mortal keep mortal other folk
and thanks for agreeing to this
interview on star talk
and chuck always good to have you dude
oh it's a pleasure all right
we got to call it quits there this has
been star talk i've been your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
as always bidding you to keep looking